in Madrid I'm Derek ray with me for
commentary is Lee Dixon and we've got
UEFA Champions League group stage action
to bring you tonight
it is Juventus against Valley San German
yeah the long road to the finals Darcy
in Game one always think that if you win
your home games and don't lose your away
games you've got a good chance of
progressing
and the old lady of Italian football
going with this starting eleven white
chicks Ken's knee starts in goal
Blaise Matuidi place with middle MP a
niche in the center of the park and the
main striker is the unmistakable
Cristiano Ronaldo and the PSG team looks
like this the neutrals favorite Gigi
Buffon still single Thiago Silva plays
alongside marquinhos in central defence
Markova Rossi starts alongside at viaje
mio in the center of the park
and the main striker today is Edinson
Cavani the Uruguayan
we have the sixth sense that I want to
do and win it back and that was a
heaven-sent opportunity to take the lead
so early first goal is so important
direct sometimes you're not ready but
you really must be ready this early in
the game well he's lost the ball come on
the shot decidedly lacking accuracy well
he had other options as well but he
chose to shoot
psg have been in building mode for many
a year now and make no mistake Li the
Champions League will be the most
coveted prize of all for them to win
yeah absolutely the group stages in the
past have not been a real problem for
them but it's just getting over that
final hurdle in order to get into
semifinals and finals and actually win
the trophy
so lots expected of them because of that
money thought they need to do
[Applause]
that will be such a bonus for them to go
again
the
[Applause]
and about playing again you've a with
the lead here but I see now mrs. Tiago
Silva I see now a radio Neymar
[Applause]
straight forward for the keeper
[Applause]
he's got forward pretty effectively here
Douglas Costa and trusty uh no Ronaldo
wasting terrific reflex action
yeah you've just got to come out and
spread yourself and hope for the best
[Applause]
and delivered by pianets not messing
around without clearance
regaining possession for his side
cleverly might well be stuck for them to
counter-attack here butchers though they
might make real incisive ball from
matsui knee
that's clear they won't complain through
sir advantage
[Applause]
and overcomes the corner miss the chance
to extend
[Applause]
Renaldo and with that they attack
fizzles out
[Music]
[Applause]
and options in the center
in San Giovanni now
[Applause]
now Kadena
Jannik
[Applause]
vanity
[Applause]
now he must favor the cross back from
the byline
now that's weenie
the effectiveness of the high price
Aventis have given us away I thankfully
we all looked forward don't we to the
various stages of the Champions League
from the group stay as a splendid ball
from Ronaldo lovely ball from Douglas
Costa
[Applause]
finishing to nail down
referee's verdict is three additional
minutes now a cameo given away
[Music]
and now Ronaldo December the chance and
a powerful weapon but just second half
has started and Polly says Yama and work
on the hands
do
padeen centavo Mina Danny Elvis now what
can we do here givanni now Robbie oh and
it's cha funny brother yo corner given
to PSG
[Applause]
now the execution of the corner and he's
clear as lines
[Applause]
historic surrounding Cristiano Ronaldo
is usually a positive one and tonight no
exception
well I've got a word for that first half
performance spectacular he was
absolutely brilliant he's got his two
goals let's see what he's got to offer
in the second half now Matt Sweeney
that's a gorgeous ball from Matt to Edie
Gabanna you been success cards attack
after attack sooner or later you're
going to score a goal
[Applause]
sadly we have to conclude that this
hasn't really been a contest but all
credits at any side committed to scoring
goals like this
mrs. Neymar
[Applause]
here's Ronaldo
[Applause]
well he doesn't have it quite on the
target late I was a great opportunity
sometimes you got a choice power or
placement he should have put his laces
through it
[Applause]
incisive pass from Douglas Costa that is
top-notch goalkeeping he had to reach
end with his hand it's all about reading
the pace of the ball and the players
feet when do I go down when do I strip
the ball did a brilliant job then
Edinson Cavani now
drumming towards go one man to beat
the PSG Torah
corner kick played over two children
capitalized there
Jannik
Geneva's lost it it's an excellent
attack from PSG but will there be an end
product
Khedira juventus have given us away
[Applause]
Thiago Silva I'm giving away
[Applause]
goodness he was right on top of the
situation to get them all but for a
state they decided but now is the time
to go to the bench
[Applause]
versus Thiago Silva
Giovanni
[Applause]
and back pay with it ten minutes select
for play in this match
now cool Sawa given away by yulian
Drexler
[Applause]
dibala that was untidy
well direct read there to intercept
[Applause]
and babay with it
givanni Alexandra now you are surely an
attempt like that never likely to
trouble the keeper no he's got
positioning right but it was a poor shot
in the end
[Applause]
here's marquinhos
mrs. Tiago Silva Neymar and just the one
minute left in normal time here and the
referee is decided to award the free
kick to PSG it's a substitution for
Juventus
[Applause]
we've been waiting to find out now we
know a minimum of three added minutes
here dibala given away
[Applause]
this game is in the history books and
Aventis have claimed all three points
from the opening game of the Champions
League season yeah really really strong
star that's what you need with five
games to go very important you stay in
the now one game at a time Derek that of
a cliche
[Applause]
you